[Music]
mr. president I hereby declare this
hooding ceremony for the candidates for
the Doctor of Philosophy or the Doctor
of the arts to be in session please be
seated
good afternoon
oh now that you responded I'm gonna have
to repeat this and really hear you good
afternoon
oh that's far better that was not in my
script by the way my name is Farnum
Jahan yawn I am honored to be presiding
over my first hooding ceremony as
president of Carnegie Mellon University
welcome to the celebration of one of
academia z' most venerable traditions a
time when Carnegie Mellon community
comes together to celebrate the
achievements of our candidates for the
degrees of Doctor of Philosophy and
Doctor of Arts as a research institution
one of the core missions of Carnegie
Mellon University is to develop talented
new scholars who can demonstrate deep
mastery of a body of knowledge
originality of thought an openness to
collaborative inquiry a doctoral
candidates as doctoral candidates you
are the embodiment of that purpose and
today is the culmination of several
years of intense scholarly pursuits
and deep immersion in your discipline
today when you truly become scholars but
you've done it you are done
you can clap if you like
[Applause]
I can almost feel the sense of relief
emanating from all of you take a deep
breath and enjoy the ceremony it might
be a bit long but every name be called
represents a fellow CMU colleague who
has reached the pinnacle of his or her
studies each with a unique journey that
has led to this very special moment so
enjoy yourselves and bask in the your
success and the success of your peers
there is no doubt that you have earned
it as we recognize your hard work and
achievements this afternoon I am
grateful to the faculty members who have
advised and supported you throughout
your studies faculty thank you for your
commitment your passion and mentorship
graduates please join me in thanking
your faculty Mentors
[Applause]
I would also like to take a moment to
thank the many people here tonight who
have made the road easier for these
dedicated men and women as they focus so
intensely on their scholarship spouses
parents grandparents children friends
this day is yours as well please join me
in expressing our thanks to family
members and friends who are here
[Applause]
throughout your doctoral studies you
have made your mark on the intellectual
landscape of this campus and you will
now may take your place among our
steamed community of scholars through
your achievements to come you will bring
honor and prestige to Carnegie Mellon
and enhanced opportunities of the
graduate students who follow you in many
cases you will change the lives of
people around the world for the better
or make significant impact on a body of
knowledge I wish you a fulfilling future
and I offer my sincere congratulations
on your achievements it is now my
pleasure to introduce Carnegie Mellon's
interim provost dr. Laurie weingartz who
will introduce this afternoon's keynote
speakers Laurie
[Applause]
well Thank You Farnum and
congratulations on your first
commencement weekend as our tenth
president of Carnegie Mellon University
it's now my great pleasure to introduce
our distinguished speaker dr. and Gemma
Frazier a leading nuclear physicist in
the United States federal government a
trailblazing champion for women and
minorities in STEM and most importantly
a Carnegie Mellon alumna last night dr.
Fraser was awarded an alumni Achievement
Award in recognition of her exceptional
accomplishments and leadership in her
field as a theoretical nuclear physicist
in the Department of Energy's National
Nuclear Security Administration dr.
Fraser manages the safety and security
of the u.s. nuclear weapons stockpile
and I'm glad she's doing it for us she
currently serves as acting director of
the inertial confinement fusion program
which advances our scientific
understanding for weapons relevant high
energy density physics for her
contributions dr. Fraser recently
received the DoD joint civilian service
commendation award and she's a
trailblazer in other ways too dr. Fraser
is the first woman and the first African
American scientist to head the inertial
confinement fusion program since it was
founded 40 years ago she was also the
first African American woman to receive
a bachelor's degree in physics from CMU
and to receive a PhD in nuclear physics
from Michigan State University she is
part of the department of energy's
minorities and engineering initiative
co-founder of power professional
opportunities for women at energy
realized and founder and CEO of
diversity science a group of scientists
and engineers expanding stem
participation and dr. Fraser has been
inspiring CMU students to forge their
own paths as keynote speaker for science
and diversity programs across campus
previously dr. Frasier was a visiting
professor at the college of
international security affairs at the
National Defense University in
Washington DC and served as professional
staff on the committee of science in the
US House of Representatives through
these many roles she's remained a strong
advocate for diversity and inclusion in
the classroom and the workplace that
includes her career long membership and
the National Society of black engineers
where she currently serves as a member
of their National Advisory Board ladies
and gentlemen please join me in giving a
warm and enthusiastic welcome to
Carnegie Mellon's own dr. and Gemma
Frazier
thank you so much for that generous
introduction I will try to live up to
those words as Laurie said I am a proud
alumni of Carnegie Mellon University
graduated 26 years ago twenty-one years
ago I was in the seats you are similar
seat getting ready to receive my PhD so
I'm honored to be able to impart some
things that I won't say our lessons but
things that I thought that I could share
with you so it's an honor to be here and
I will say that when I was getting ready
to graduate I knew I wanted to use my
degree but I wasn't quite sure that I
wanted to go the traditional path which
would have been a postdoc and then going
into academia so what I ended up doing
was going to into science policy and
working for the US House of
Representatives which meant that it was
great access and a great opportunity but
as my mom will tell you if you give her
a chance
not the greatest salary so she had
invested a lot into my education but I
felt that it was something I needed to
do to broaden my horizons so I feel like
I used my degree but didn't go that
traditional path so when I searched
within myself to see if there's
something that I could impart I did feel
like there were three things that came
to mind and I will go through those
three things and hopefully you guys will
see the value of them as you reach the
other side of this momentous occasion so
I will say the other thing I had to
search within myself was what was I
thinking when I went through my hooding
ceremony and I can say with absolute
certainty that I don't remember anything
from that day so I don't know if it was
the excitement if it was kind of a
little bit of apprehension about what
was coming if it was fatigue or if it
was just the chaos of having family and
friends in here but I it's a complete
blank for me so I say this to the
friends and family of the graduates you
will be the institutional memory for
today
so so just keep that in mind but you
graduate you will have the photo so
there will be that so I will say that
for whatever reason my family does
retain that memory and so as you
graduate as you go through this hooding
ceremony as you go through commencement
you know take the opportunity to kind of
breathe it in and pause and really
recognize the level of achievement that
you've achieved today and make sure that
you know your phones are down right that
you're not thinking about where you've
just come from or where you're going
next and that you're actually present
just take five minutes to do that for me
if you would and if and for yourself so
that when you look back on this it's not
the white horse in a blizzard that that
my memory seems to be that I just can't
recall what happened there I just know
that I was glad that I made it past the
finish line which I'm sure some of you
are feeling right now and I'm on to
greater things so if you think about
what's coming next I will say the first
thing that I want to share is that it
doesn't matter how you get out of the
gate it doesn't matter if you're slow
out of the gate if you're fast out of
the gate you've been giving all the
tools you've attained a level of
excellence that will stay with you and
your muscle memory will kick in and it
doesn't matter if you take a Hill job
for about $47,000 or if you go into you
know investment baking you know whether
you get out fast slow however whatever
metric you use you'll get there in the
end
so that's something valuable to know be
kind be gentle with yourselves in these
first you know days and months after
receiving your PhD it's all gonna work
out nothing to worry about there so glad
I can delay those fears I would also say
that you know give your chance to self a
chance to kind of live in whatever
feelings you have right now if you feel
like you're going to miss graduate
school
you're gonna miss the freedom the
intellectual curiosity the flexible
schedule the concentration in your field
what if you feel like you're gonna miss
graduate school you're right if you feel
like you won't miss graduate school
you're also right so you know you're
going to have those ups and downs I'm
sure there are things you won't miss
maybe the hours of being a teaching
assistant maybe passing the unreasonably
enthusiastic undergraduate students as
you go from class to class weaving
through them and then also you know the
shoestring budget there are things that
you're definitely not going to miss
about graduate school so you're right
both ways but it's important to
understand that you know those kind of
ups and downs and that kind of duality
is not going to end as you go forward
but will what will be different is you
in that you will have as I said those
skills those capabilities kind of the
PhD behind your name and what that
exemplifies in terms of what you've been
able to attain and the level of
excellence you've been able to achieve
so while the circumstance won't be
different you will be different by what
today has wrought and the work that you
put in over the last three to seven
years depending maybe longer so the
second thing I will say is that
excellence always pays off so and I will
take this as being one of the linchpins
of say we'll call it dr. fraisers
handbook right so being lazy about
things never pays off even if you get
away with it being mediocre may or may
not pay off you're kind of rolling the
dice with how that works
big but being excellent always pays off
right you may not get the immediate
recognition you may not have had to do
you know the extra hours worth of work
but it will be a personal best for you
if you know that you've brought all your
skills and abilities to the table and
what this PhD allows you to do is
know the level of excellence that you're
capable of and be able to draw upon that
in the coming years and so I would think
even more than your subject matter
expertise it's really that level of
excellence that's that's going to hold
you in great esteem and really prove to
you and prove to others that you know
you are meant to be at the top of your
particular industry so that excellence
is something that is is not going to get
old I have been pulled from a mini a
situation where I was not happy or
satisfied there may have been
interpersonal things with people who are
jockeying for a position
you're gonna love those office politics
too I have to say but it is your your
brand and people knowing what you're
capable of and what you bring to the
table that is really going to make all
the difference going forward so the
first lesson be easy with yourself in
these early days the second is that
excellence is always going to pay off at
some point and to remember that and the
third is that you know this PhD it's
important to see it not as an
entitlement but to see it as a
responsibility right so as you go
through this hooding think about it as
donning a cape right you are now a
superhero right you now have you know
with the ear you have the control you
have the options right and so it is your
responsibility to be that voice of truth
it is your responsibility to have
courage when those around you may not
have courage and it is also your
responsibility to be a change agent and
so that's something that as you go
through this ceremony and as you move
forward please remember that there is a
responsibility that goes with that and I
think everyone on this stage here is is
aware of that I know that I've tried to
keep that close to my heart as I've gone
forward and I'd advise you just just be
mindful of that and it gives you a great
power in knowing that even if
standing alone if you're standing on the
side of right everything will work out
in the end so with that I'd say be
gentle with yourself
always strive for excellence and be a
hero so congratulations and I wish you
all the best in the future
[Applause]
well thank you dr. Frasier very
inspiring words for a solvent to live up
to our students will not only benefit
from your advice but also from the
stellar example that you've set
throughout your career thank you thank
you for your service to our nation and
to our community thank you we will now
commence with the hooding of the dr.
candidates the deans will call forward
the candidates by college and we'll
announce the names of the candidates and
where we'll be beginning with the
College of Engineering
good evening I'm Jim Garrett Dean of the
we will now hood the doctoral candidates
for the College of Engineering we will
start with the department of biomedical
engineering Diane Laverne legette Nelson
drug delivery via / fluorocarbon
emulsions a novel treatment method for
bacterial respiratory infections and
acute respiratory failure we will now
call the doctoral candidates for
chemical engineer Travis R majeure force
propagation and mammalian cell systems
and the relevance of mechanically
integrated cell
[Applause]
Rebeca ball oral delivery of lipid
nanoparticles with si RNA for the
treatment of intestinal diseases
[Applause]
Tony Tony M Bechtel micromechanical
modeling of Brownian spheroids in
oscillatory shear flow
[Applause]
Alex Joseph bertuccio metal species and
surfing and impact of on bacterial
populations and community behavior
[Applause]
blake john blyer droplet based
approaches to probe complex behavior in
colloidal fluids with high composition
resolution
[Applause]
John Patrick Eason trust region
strategies for surrogate based
optimization
[Applause]
Lisa Nicole kazoo its shorts interfering
RNA loaded lipid oeid nanoparticles and
the immune system
[Applause]
Britany Alexandra Nord Marc efficacy of
Moringa oleifera proteins as coagulants
in a sustainable sand filter for
drinking water
[Applause]
shriek on rajagopal on design and
maintenance planning problems in
commodity distribution and chemical site
networks
[Applause]
Ihram shun alloy catalysis across
composition space
[Applause]
weh-weh
one advances in Newton based barrier
methods for nonlinear programming
[Applause]
Justin Blake Weinberg competitive IgG
adsorption on protein a chromatography
resins and improving resin performance
with pegylated ligands
[Applause]
ciao ciao ooh high throughput assessment
of multi-component alloy materials
[Applause]
we will now hold the candidates from the
Department of Civil and environmental
engineering Adam Lightner call Walder
cadwalter impacts of bromide and
nitrogen wastewater discharges on
downstream drinking water treatment
plant disinfection by-products nacet
console Accio chemical interactions on
hydraulic fracturing biocides with
natural pyrite
Kyle Gore Kowski the morphology and
equilibria of levitated secondary
organic particles under controlled
conditions
[Applause]
Corie
David Harper transitioning to a
connected and automated vehicle
environment opportunities for improving
transportation
[Applause]
[Music]
Navid calls em soft multifunctional
composite using liquid metal
[Applause]
avi Khayyam Mirsky environmental and
policy implications of vehicle
automation and electrification Joe
Dallas more probing Nano specific
interactions between bacteria and
antimicrobial nanoparticles using
microbial community changes and gene
expression
[Applause]
Xiang Fei son modeling the biota
population impact on polychlorinated
biphenyls transport and simulating PCBs
anaerobic bio degradation in the lake
system
we will now hood the doctoral candidates
from the Department of Electrical and
Computer Engineering shall you buy micro
magnetic modeling of thin film segmented
medium for microwave-assisted magnetic
recording Chandrasekar bhagavata robust
Posen variant face recognition using 3d
thin plates spline spatial transformer
networks
[Applause]
Aleksei : system support for
intermittent computing
[Applause]
amid data fairness and privacy
violations in black box personalization
systems detection and defenses
[Applause]
boots off olia adaptive distributed
caching for scalable machine learning
services
[Applause]
Nabeel al-hasawi the development
optimization and integration of inline
phase change switches for reconfigurable
RF systems Mateen gokon goon a high
dynamic range CMOS MEMS capacitive
accelerometer array with drift
compensation Jun Han advantages and
risks of sensing for cyber physical
security
[Applause]
Thomas C Jackson building efficient
neuromorphic networks in hardware with
mixed signal techniques and emerging
technologies Stephen M crew zyk optimal
graph filter design for large-scale
random networks
[Applause]
Patrick Yanis Emmanuel logic ultrasonic
ranging and indoor localization for
mobile devices non-key one-way
contextual recurrent level-set networks
and recurrent residual networks for
semantic labeling
[Applause]
Jonathan my principle network analysis
Nathan Donald McCulloh diagnosing
user-visible performance problems in
production high-density wireless
networks Benjamin Nieuwenhuis designing
a logic test chip for optimal test and
diagnosis
[Applause]
suja pond indoor human information
acquisition through physical vibrations
[Applause]
saerom park transport transforms and its
application to demultiplexing orbital
angular momentum beams nia s Peters
collaborative communication interruption
management system or C Sims modeling
interruption timings being prasada and
topic modeling for human machine teens
[Applause]
Steven Sienna improving the design and
use of correlation filters in visual
tracking
[Applause]
Rahul Singh design techniques for
frequency reconfigurability in multi
standard RF transceivers UN T on
privacy-preserving information-sharing
in modern and emerging platforms
[Applause]
Richard Michael Varys a systematic
approach for obtaining performance on
matrix-like operations
[Applause]
chen-wong quality of experience based
management and control for large-scale
video on-demand system in the cloud
[Applause]
chanting shoe investigation of
modulation methods to synthesize
high-performance resonator based RF MEMS
components
[Applause]
Felix Jaffe zoom unconstrained peri
ocular face recognition from
reconstructive dictionary learning to
generative deep learning and beyond G
ding you learning structured and deep
representations for traffic scene
understanding Chang Hong Jong deep
understanding of urban mobility from
cityscape web cams
[Applause]
we will now hood doctoral candidates
from the Department of engineering and
public policy
Jaime Bonin Roca leaders and followers
challenges and opportunities in the
adoption of metal additive manufacturing
technologies Travis
Sergio Emil Carlos framing a new nuclear
resna saans through environmental
competitiveness community
characteristics and cost mitigation
through passive safety
[Applause]
Rebecca Elaine says battery energy
storage for maturing markets performance
cost perceptions and environmental
impacts Michael Craig inva economic and
environmental costs benefits and
trade-offs of low-carbon technologies in
the electric power sector
Barry Davis DeWitt measurement of
health-related quality of life
preference aggregation exclusion and
Public Policy Michael James Fisher
integrating demand-side resources into
the electric grid economic and
environmental considerations Daniel
Earl Gingrich evaluating and avoiding
risk trade-offs in water treatment
[Applause]
Sonia manganese impacts on safety and
air pollution from transportation
policies in Bogota Colombia
[Applause]
Chevonne yuan mo gosh high-growth
entrepreneurship a multi-level
perspective on firm growth and growth
policy
[Applause]
Jose Fernando Prada ensuring the
reliable operation of the power grid
state-based and distributed approaches
to scheduling energy and contingency
reserves
[Applause]
both young young essays on
telecommunications management
understanding consumers switch search
and purchase behaviors we will now hood
the doctor'll candidates from the
Department of material science and
engineering Ross William Cunningham
defect formation mechanisms in powder
bed metal additive manufacturing
[Applause]
Jennifer rose pages semiconductor
contacts for nano electronics tin
sulfide nano ribbons tin sulfide thin
films and silver nano wire based
transparent conductors
Ryan Keely Santini Harrison
relationships between material function
and micro structural shapes as measured
by moment invariants
[Applause]
Deepu Kumar development of a reliable
kinetic model for ladle refining of
steel
[Applause]
you hon Liang deep ultraviolet revile at
light emitters based on aluminum gallium
nitride semiconductor heterostructures
[Applause]
su dito Mandel texture and
microstructure in two phase titanium
alloys
[Applause]
Ellen right Fleur investigation of
intrinsic and tunable properties of
two-dimensional transition metal detail
Kajin IDEs for optical applications we
will now hood the doctoral candidates
from the Department of Mechanical
Engineering brian fisher part
temperature effects in powder bed fusion
additive manufacturing of titanium 6-4
[Applause]
norge on EHR hulu computational design
and evaluation methods for empowering
non experts in digital fabrication yong
li characterization of air pollutant and
greenhouse gas emissions from energy use
and energy production processes in the
United States
[Applause]
Gyeongju lead urban aerosol spatio
temporal variation and source
characterization
[Applause]
Ruthann shoe sous-sous fan-xiu gnuhata
micromachining metrology measurement and
analysis of dynamic tooltip trajectory
when using ultra high speed spindles
[Applause]
rage up on layer green micromachining of
ceramics feasibility and micro machine
ability
[Applause]
Patriota pit promo Pithom numerical
modeling of thermal and mechanical
behaviors in selective laser sintering
of metals
[Applause]
Luke seamy methods for the expansion of
additive manufacturing process space and
the development of insight to process
monitoring methodologies irva enhancing
the structural performance of additively
manufactured object
[Applause]
William Leon Ching way new Studies on
thermal transport in metal additive
manufacturing processes and products
shall dong way highly localized
refinement using truncation mechanism on
unstructured quadrilateral and
hexahedral meshes
[Applause]
Jackson wire co-development of soft
actuation systems for use in
human-centered applications
[Applause]
good evening I'm Dan Martin Dean of the
College of Fine Arts
we will now hood the doctoral candidates
from the School of Architecture oleate
on om olo exploring communication in
multidisciplinary building design teams
[Applause]
ciao ding CFD based coupled indoor and
outdoor interactions or CIO I for
building natural ventilation in urban
environment
[Applause]
rohini Shrivastava integrating financial
environmental and human capital the
triple bottom line for high-performance
investments in the built environment we
will now hood the PhD candidates for the
School of Design Michael Warren Arnold
Mage's designing civic conversations
things and facilitation in high stakes
and difficult conversations
[Applause]
deeper butoh Lia critical Jew guard a
post normal design framework for design
early marginal practices
[Applause]
de mogi on a few one-design enabled
recall moaning the impact of platforms
on contributing to new Commons
[Applause]
good afternoon I'm Richard shyness the
Dean of the Dietrich College of
Humanities and Social Sciences will now
hood the candidates from the Department
of English Anna Lee cook collaborating
in public how openness shapes global
warming articles in Wikipedia Derek G
Handley strategies for Performing
citizenship rhetorical citizenship and
the black freedom movement
[Applause]
Julian Elizabeth Reineke three sheets to
the wind
the Jolly Jack tar and 18th century
British masculinity
[Applause]
Ryan T rhetoric self-regulation and
writing transfer how students navigate
new writing situations
[Applause]
djay salt the dissenting academies and
the literary politics of the 1790s
[Applause]
Jamie Theresa Maddy Smith rights and
rights revolution performance gender and
religion in British novels of the 1790s
[Applause]
Pavitra Tantra Goethe contesting green
imperialism ecology and rights in South
Asian literature
[Applause]
we'll now hood the candidates in the
Department of History Jonathan David
knew from Civil War to civic reform
Grand Army veterans in the Progressive
Era
[Applause]
Rachel Oppenheimer of prisons and
polities the Black Panther Party Irish
Republican Army and radical
socio-political organization
1966 to 1983 will now put the candidates
in the Department of Modern Languages
Hwang Lee usage-based approaches to
pragmatic development in computer
mediated communication or CMC sentence
final particles among l2 Chinese
learners
[Applause]
Ashley Adams Weber the making of a new
comer identity exploring the social
experiences of new arrival English
language learners to a recently
diversified small US city during times
of political and economic challenge
you'll now give doctorates and
philosophy to the candidates in
philosophy Flores P Van Dorn on the
formalization of higher inductive types
and synthetic homotopy Theory will now
hood the candidates in the Department of
Psychology Tina Liu understanding
cortical reorganization in the visual
system following surgical resection in
children
jingtian understanding percentages
[Applause]
we'll now hood candidates in the
Department of Social and decision
sciences David Rohde abstraction and
intermediation the implications of
behavioral decision-making for three
applications in finance
[Applause]
we'll now hood candidates in the
Department of statistics and data
Sciences Moria Cuellar causal reasoning
and data analysis in the law definition
estimation and usage of the probability
of causation
[Applause]
federico gonzalez limit order book
models and applications
[Applause]
Nicholas Kim local structure and
inference enlarged random graphs
giuseppe vinci statistical inference
about functional connectivity from multi
neuron data Jersey atom was Erick model
selection and stopping rules for high
dimensional forward selection
[Applause]
Ling's way zoo learning from high
dimensional and noisy transcriptome data
[Applause]
Groff known my name is Amaya Krishnan
Dean at the Heinz College of information
systems and public policy will now hurt
candidates for the doctoral philosophy
from the school of information systems
and management
kwan/wong understanding consumer
behavior with cross channel digital
marketing now hood candidates for the
doctoral philosophy from the School of
Public Policy and management
Filipa leveraging upon large-scale media
and communications data sets for
socio-economic and policy analysis good
evening
I'm Rebecca Dortch Dean at the Mellon
college of science that we will hood the
doctoral candidates from Biological
Sciences
Agnetha Kadem investigations into the
role of inter and intra stream quorum
sensing in pneumococcal pathogenesis
Lydia a perkins built for the daiwei
flora genic tools for protein traffic
[Applause]
swathi when cut sorting of oligomers
proteins implications in toxin
trafficking and quality control
[Applause]
we will now hood the doctoral students
from the department of chemistry use a
hn controlling metal nanoclusters with
atomic precision and their catalytic
applications
[Applause]
d Hara Jo Rothman organization of
inorganic complexes in supra molecular
structures based on peptides and peptide
nucleic acids
[Applause]
Isaac and Mills synthetic tuning of the
properties of transition metal complexes
towards solar energy conversion
applications
[Applause]
Jonathan Abel poorest judicious design
of transition metal complexes for
photochemical energy conservation
conversion Heather dawn stout
spectroscopic characterization of
transition metal complexes with special
electronic properties
chalk wall site design strategies and
synthesis of bio fiend based organic
materials
[Applause]
Jenova Rose Warner synthesis properties
and reactivity of sulfonamide new tamil
oxidation catalysts
[Applause]
Andrew White's spectroscopy and d/f
calculations of a flavo dye iron enzyme
identifying new structures and nitric
oxide intermediates of the nitric oxide
reduction cycle we will now heard the
doctoral students from mathematical
sciences Jing Wang escrow and clawback
[Applause]
slav key role models and methods for
one-dimensional approximations to point
cloud data
[Applause]
Andrew zuker New Directions in the
abstract topological dynamics of Polish
groups
[Applause]
we will now heard the doctoral students
from the Department of Physics Lu could
Bhavna
electric field control of magnetization
switching in magnetic tunnel junctions
[Applause]
Rebecca eels structural studies of
peripheral membrane proteins involved in
hiv-1 infection and propagation Jun Li
two dimensional materials growth
characterization and simulation
[Applause]
Sean Lynn Lou fully relativistic full
potential multiple scattering theory
method and applications
[Applause]
Zhang Hao luau
lyman-alpha intensity mapping via grism
spectro tomography
[Applause]
Michelle nah my walk out now maka
cosmology with galaxy cluster dynamics
using machine learning and forward
modeling Jason Ranger an algorithmic
application of orientation relationship
geometries to reconstruct high
temperature phase microstructures
applications in steel and additively
manufactured titanium
Michael Justin's type calibrations for
charged particle tracking and
measurements of Omega photo production
with the glue X detector Hong Joo Joo
gravitational redshift sin galaxies and
galaxy clusters
[Applause]
hello my name is Andrew Moore I am
honoured to be Dean of the most advanced
school of computer science on the planet
we are now hurt candidates from the
human-computer interaction from the
department of computer science Jessie
and do Nietzche
annotating and automatically tagging
constructions of causal language
[Applause]
Jin Cheng Cheng enabling data-driven
optimization of quality of experience in
Internet applications
[Applause]
as chica Raman kuda bux distributed
learning in referral networks
[Applause]
Yixing low architectural techniques for
improving NAND flash memory reliability
math UK mukajee eliminating adverse
control plane interactions in
independent network systems
[Applause]
David Naylor architectural support for
managing privacy trade-offs in the
Internet
[Applause]
shayok sin influence directed
explanations for machine learning
[Applause]
[Music]
Michael J Sullivan low-level concurrent
programming using the relaxed memory
calculus
[Applause]
bruno favela secure large-scale
outsource services founded on
trustworthy code executions
[Applause]
hongyi Asian methods for reducing
unnecessary computation on false
mappings in read mapping Danny you
augmented reality visualization for
autonomous robots will now hook the
candidates from the human-computer
interaction Institute
Selvig does social cybersecurity
reshaping security through an empirical
understanding of human social behavior
Samantha Finkelstein rapport and science
discourse with by dialectal virtual
peers
[Applause]
Eric Ofsted projective replay analysis a
reflective approach for aligning
educational games to their goals
[Applause]
[Music]
Kelly rivers automated data-driven hint
generation for learning programming
[Applause]
Jeffrey M rosette Stoltz a ski
uncovering nuances in complex data
through focus and context visualizations
[Applause]
Daniel J Tess how geotagged social media
can inform modern travelers
[Applause]
we will now put candidates from the
language technology institute Alavi
Belgica speech synthesis from found data
Leonid oyster efficient and accurate
non-metric K&N search with applications
to text matching
[Applause]
Jin Lai Chen visual knowledge learning
just in two features for search and
understanding of noisy conversational
speech Jay Jiujiang computational
modeling of metaphor in discourse
[Applause]
su Jai Kumar Java a relation centric
view of semantic representation learning
[Applause]
will now hurt candidates from the
machine learning departments way dive
learning with staleness
[Applause]
Kirstin early dynamic question ordering
obtaining useful information while
reducing user burden ahmed hefney
efficient methods for prediction and
control in partially observable
environments
[Music]
Shashank check I'm ready new
optimization methods for modern machine
learning Hyuk seeing Wang new paradigms
and optimality guarantees in statistical
learning and estimation
[Applause]
Jingsheng statistical approach for
functionally validating transcription
factor binding x' using population snip
and gene expression data
[Applause]
and suyang sublinear time optimization
for high dimensional learning will now
put the candidates from the robotics
Institute
Nathan Benjamin Brooks situational
awareness and mixed initiative markup
for human robot team plans Jonathan
Michael boots key planning for a small
team of heterogeneous robots from
collaborative exploration to
collaborative localization
[Applause]
Laura V Highland algorithms
implementation and Studies on eating
with a shared control robot arm
Humphrey who adapting to context in
robot state estimation
[Applause]
shovin Jeff Donnie acting under
uncertainty for information gathering
and shared autonomy
[Applause]
so Sanka nagavalli algorithms for timing
and sequencing behaviors in robotic
swarms Venkatraman marry onon
deliberative perception
[Applause]
stefanos Nikolaidis mathematical models
of adaptation in human robot
collaboration
[Applause]
Nathan D autumn planning for
sun-synchronous lunar polar roving
[Applause]
Robert Eugene Paolini data-driven
statistical models of robotic
manipulation
I rodents roof Autzen Ranga Prasad
probabilistic approaches for pose
estimation
Abin after stava discovering and
leveraging visual structure for
large-scale recognition
[Applause]
breelan melissa
kane styler using multiple fidelity
models in motion planning
[Applause]
Abhijeet telev a doula lidar simulation
for robotic application development
modeling and evaluation Mary milz
vasquez reasoning about spatial patterns
of human behavior during group
conversations with robots
[Applause]
Aaron Venkatraman training strategies
for time series learning for prediction
filtering and reinforcement learning
[Applause]
young Wang learning to learn for small
sample visual recognition Jia Jie Zhao
harnessing task mechanics for robotic
pushing and grasping good afternoon
everyone
my name is Bob Damon I'm Dean of the
Tepper School of Business
we will now hood the doctors candidates
from The Temper School
Emilio bazzetta
essays in financial economics
[Applause]
Steele jnos despot el despertar case
expertise attribution and ad blocking in
the world of online marketing young John
Kim
forecasting unethical behavior using the
hidden information distribution and
evaluation or hide model Leela
Aarthi nageshwara new innovative models
and service operations
[Applause]
but Colonel Paul essays in asset pricing
Thiago say huh
essays on post Optima - let's try that
again
essays on post Optima tality lift and
project and scheduling
[Music]
[Applause]
Christian John draught matcha decision
diagram relaxations for integer
programming Erica Van Sant
essays on public economics
very good Evelyn yingxiong
intra-organizational mobility movers
incumbents and communication networks
[Applause]
on behalf of all the deans and the
administration congratulations to all
the new doctors and their families
[Applause]
wasn't that wonderful we're so proud of
our distinguished and accomplished CMU
scholars I know you want to clap for
them again so I'm going to give you an
opportunity please join me in
congratulating all of our graduates
I want to express my gratitude to our
Dean's Dean's thank you for
participating in today's ceremony for
all that you do to contribute to our
community through your leadership and by
setting such a wonderful role model
example thank you very much
now that you've seen all of our doctoral
recipients once again I want to I want
to take a moment to congratulate the
faculty members and advisers who worked
so closely with our graduates especially
those of you who have participated in
today's hooding ceremony I can speak
from personal experience that attending
the ceremony as an advisor comes with
its own remarkable sense of pride we
appreciate your dedication to these
students and your care and attention to
nurturing not only their careers and
scholarship but also their well-being
thank you very much
[Applause]
this concludes our hooding ceremony for
2018 please note that these degrees will
be formally conferred at Sunday's
commencement ceremony in gesslin Stadium
and diplomas represent will be presented
in special ceremonies taking place
throughout the weekend once again
congratulations to all of our doctoral
candidates for their accomplishments and
best wishes for your continued success
you are invited to join us for a
reception in the foyer following the
procession at this time please rise for
the singing of the alma mater led by
Hannah she a graduating senior in the
College of Fine Arts
here spangled wildernesses roared the
fountains of the West the Soviet strife
and stresses brought the setlist crimson
crossed
non-dominate and glory graces gypsy time
[Music]
[Applause]